y ahora regresa del frente de batalla es
para médica y su vehículo es un ejemplo
la ferocidad de los combates
la bomba cayó al lado del carro pero
nosotros estábamos en el show
la vida de los militares y civiles
atrapados en el conflicto depende de
cientos de integrantes del cuerpo médico
del ejército para quienes la guerra no
comenzó el 24 de febrero
durante 8 años aquí en el frente de
batalla cada mes tenemos soldados
abortos
vitaly conducción a las ambulancias que
recoge heridos de gravedad en el frente
de batalla
el actuar de los rusos ha cambiado
significativamente comparado con 2014 el
calibre de las armas ha cambiado es más
grande y más poderoso y abarca mucho más
espacio que antes
en esta nueva etapa también atacan con
insistencia a las misiones médicas los
hospitales de campaña están en lugares
secretos muchas ambulancias tapan la
cruz roja que las identifica y apagan
las luces en medio de la noche
tenemos rumores los llamamos la
frecuencia elefante y vienen del frente
de batalla
esos rumores dicen que los rusos reciben
dinero adicional por atacar unidades de
transporte médico y doctores es como una
cacería polvo
el doctor andrei borisenko tiene a su
cargo una de las unidades médicas más
experimentadas del ejército ucraniano su
misión es atender a los pacientes graves
que necesitan tratamiento médico urgente
los estabilizan y luego las talar
hospitales militares urbanos aprobé
cuesta personas de aquel acá hemos sido
atacados varias veces y hemos tenido que
evacuar tan rápido como se puede pero
nuestro trabajo es estar aquí tenemos
que salvar vidas
este paciente se volcó en su vehículo
cuando huía de un ataque la mayoría de
las personas que atienden en este
hospital sufren de traumas
el doctor andrew y se reintegró al
ejército desde el primer día de la
guerra en esta sala de cirugía
improvisada los doctores dicen que sus
llamados cuidar de quienes ponen la vida
en riesgo por defender a los ucranianos
su labor es tan importante que las
fuerzas rusas intentan desmoralizar los
y eliminarlos pero en este objetivo
tampoco han tenido éxito